we are indeed with a linear domingue as
one of the rating favorites going into
this event linear first of all welcome
to the show uh I want to start with your
first round game a big clash between
yourself and Fabiano caruana you were
playing Black pieces and it felt like
you actually had a tremendous
opportunity uh to win that game how did
you feel about it yeah I felt that I had
a big Advantage somehow after dope I
didn't remember very well but the
opening but I think I
made some at least sensible moves and I
all of a sudden got a much better
position I uh I knew it of course I was
trying to convert but somehow I think it
was defending well and I missed a couple
of chances of course uh a big Miss there
but it's it's normal how do you usually
see those type of games you missed but
you also played a great game with the
black pieces equalized not only that but
you got a better position out of the
opening does that give you a boost of
confidence or do you feel bad that you
missed the chance I mean in terms of the
result is fine because it's uh with
black against one of the one of the
favorites but of course when you look at
the game it also it's a bit
disappointing not to not to win that
position but it's I mean it's something
you have to get used to like especially
if I would defends very well it's quite
tough uh it's difficult to beat him so I
think yeah nothing out of the ordinary
absolutely and he came with a very
interesting idea against Ray Robson but
let's talk about today's uh game did you
feel any pressure coming from Darius not
too much I mean I I had prepared this
idea with Rook E8 which is very
interesting in this line uh with the
idea to
drop the bishop back to f8 in case of A3
because I think normally they play
Knight C6 instead of rookie 8 and then
uh A3 United Bishop D6 and something
like rookie one and uh it's a
complicated position but Rook E8 the
point is to be able to play Bishop f8 in
case of A3 and then in the future black
can play G6 Bishop G7 in in some
positions playing against the isolated
Pawn so uh but he went for the most
solid option which is to to take on D5
and then after Ed position is is very
symmetrical and it's very hard to really
we hope for for more than a draw I think
there were some interesting lines like
after this queen H4 move
uh yeah G3 I mean rookie one is also
possible but then I take on F4
and uh yeah queen of four Queen takes
and then Bishop D7 that's very draw
which because there is yeah Pawn D4 is
hanging and Bishop B3 there is night
before
um well yeah Bishop B1 Rook C8 and black
is uh at some point another course in
exchange this night for the bishop right
I like it still actually appear yeah so
G frequent E4 uh here I think yeah Queen
D5 was maybe an option but then I
thought takes on F4 Bishop takes Bishop
E6
and it could be risky for white because
the G3
uh
made the light squares on the king side
too weak and black can have some chances
there it's probably eight Bishop D5
right at some point you have some
problems on the long Diagon yeah white
has two Bishops but black is too active
and my pieces are really well placed
here you don't have to be careful as the
engine is pointed out if we need four F5
and then somehow I'll take on D4 or put
the bishop on D5 and
looks excellent for black so I was
hoping for something like this but after
Queen takes E4 and and Knight takes D5
uh yeah it's it's very
uh yeah I wasn't sure about bgp5 but I
thought that uh that's a beautiful move
yeah probably yeah right initially I
thought that maybe he can try Bishop
takes H7 but it looks too risky for for
white yeah it takes 95 Bishop takes A7
uh but with such
um squares on the king side here Rook D2
of course which page three Knight F3
yeah this will get scary of course I
mean after B3 there's no like a win or
something at least I didn't see but uh
but the position is so great that I I
probably don't need to to win right away
to uh to have a great time here good
luck so and your assessment was correct
because actually the engine is saying
that after G5 or F6 yeah I thought
rookie six but they are basically the
same like my position is is really it's
really excellent here favorite online no
risk at all so
yeah Bishop E2 essentially kills the
game because now it's just by force
draw which hand game so yeah linear uh
you have built up quite an experience at
the USS championships but now this time
is different there's 13 Rounds when is
the last time you played such a long
event yeah I don't remember but it was a
long time ago it reminds me of the old
days I I remember I played some
tournaments back in Cuba where we had
like uh it was more than 15 rounds for
sure like something like 17 or something
like that so but it was long time ago uh
usually we don't get more than 11 rounds
nowadays but yeah it's uh it's quite a
tough tournament uh but uh it's a chance
to to to prove yourself and and try to
do well so that's that's what I'll try
are you enjoying this tense competition
for such a long prolonged periods of
time
I don't enjoy too much the the tension
uh I prefer when it's over
all the detention uh is is over and you
can just sleep without having to worry
about uh you know Berlin or Patrol
such things uh I I tend to sleep much
better in in those cases but of course I
I enjoy playing I mean it's otherwise I
couldn't survive
uh for for so many years so yeah it's
it's always nice to be able to to play
against these guys and and and and and
and it's a challenge that I welcome
Anastasia you have a question yeah I was
wondering how difficult it was for a
year to play this day when his friend
livon aronel and competitor ligonaronian
had birthday and uh what did he what did
they do after the game
I she asked how difficult it was for you
to play against Levon when you had
birthday
oh well I didn't know I didn't remember
during the game so it wasn't difficult
but uh
um I'm glad that uh that the game was a
draw because somehow I of course uh if I
win I spoil his uh birthday and he's
such a nice guy you know a dear friend
and also too I almost gave him a nice
present but
uh but yeah I think a draw was was a
really cool result for for such an
occasion yeah exactly thank you thank
you Lanier and good luck in the rest of
your games thank you all right good luck
indeed uh linear